okay so roger kelly was the grand dragon
from maryland
he would later go on to become an
imperial wizard all right
anyway he says yeah i know roger roger
was my grand dragon i said listen man
i need you to hook me up with mr kelly
i'm going to write a book on the klan
and i want to interview him
oh daryl i can't do that man i said why
not you're not in the clan anymore
i can't bring a black man to see the
grand dragon you know we both be in
trouble
i said but you're not in the clan
anymore it doesn't matter
he did not want to do it i begged and
pleaded with him
to uh to give me uh roger kelly's
address i said well look
you said you know that you got to return
this mask he said yeah
i said give me his address and phone
number i'll go to his house i'll return
it for you
he snatched that thing right out of my
hand said no way
and he was dead serious and so i said
well look
just give me his address i will meet
with him on my own
he didn't want to do that finally after
20 minutes of begging and pleading
he can send it to giving me mr kelly's
personal information
provided i not tell mr kelly where i got
it from
i said okay so then he told me about
this bar
up in thurmont maryland now you know
thurmont maryland because it's the home
of camp david
the uh presidential retreat okay it was
also one of the headquarters for the
klan
it's just a little tiny town right
outside of frederick
and uh still in frederick county and um
anyway it's the national headquarters
uh no it was the the maryland
headquarters okay for
that faction and so um
anyway um he says you know there's a bar
there
it's a clan bar not mean that the clan
owns it but they hang out there
and they gather there every saturday
night unless they're out of town
rallying somewhere something like that
they'll be there he says you know when
you first walk in now the clan doesn't
own it just hang out there
he describes it to me when you first
walk in there'll be a row of booths off
to the left
the first two booths closest closest to
the door where you come in
are reserved for the clan right
he says you know you probably find roger
kelly there on a saturday night he says
i don't guarantee you that he'll talk to
you but you're safer to approach him in
a public place
right because anybody can go in the
public place rather than try to
you know go on his property i said all
right so he drew me a little map
how to get there now i'm a full-time
musician
so you know i can't be giving up a
saturday night to go chase the clan
around
and so uh my secretary books my band
and so i asked her i figured you know
well sunday's still part of the uh
weekend
you know i knew i had some gigs on some
sundays but some sundays i had off
i asked her you know what sundays do i
have off she named me a few
i picked one i said okay i'm gonna go
find roger kelly maybe he'll be there on
sunday as well
so she wants to go now mary is white
i said no that's all i need right walk
into a clan bar
black guy walks into a clan bar with a
white lady yeah you're sure to find the
class that's right for trouble yeah
right exactly
so i said no you know not for your
safety not for mine either
so she but she insisted upon going so
i said all right but you know you're
coming at your own risk he said all
right
so we found that sunday she and i drive
up there to thurmont
and uh the guy gave me perfect
directions boom boom boom there it was
so we're like right across the street
from it we're looking at it like four or
five little steps
onto the stoop and then you go through
the door
so i said okay you know i'm trying to
think
how am i gonna walk in this place uh
it's on a sunday
um with this white lady you know you
know
you know we need a plan so i said okay
you know let's get out i'm gonna walk in
first i want you to walk in right behind
me
if i turn around and face you start
running
and i'll be behind you and she says okay
so we got out locked the car we walked
right in
as soon as i walked in all i saw on the
back of the back wall was this big
uh confederate flag off to my right
was this long wooden bar and a long
mirror behind the bar
and scotch taped to the mirror was an
article from the washington post which
is our big paper around there
with a picture of roger kelly you know i
never met him but you know i knew what
he looked like i seen him on tv and i've
seen him in the papers
i collect all that stuff right so the
washington post had interviewed him
about something and
somebody had cut it out and put it up
there and i had the same article
so i knew i was in the right place and
or the wrong place depending on how you
want to look at it
and uh then over here were the booths
and there there are those first two
booths you know the guy told me we're
reserved for the clan and the other
booths behind them
and uh nobody was in any of the booths
you know
and there may be no more that i would
say six or seven people in the whole
place
including the bartender a couple guys in
the back playing pool a couple guys just
milling around
some guy sitting at the bar and so
you know i didn't know if anybody there
was clan or not planned you know they're
all white
but that does not mean that they're all
a clan because uh
thurmont is an all-white town but not
every white person there is in the clan
in fact most white people in thermo
wanted the clan out of there
you know they didn't like the clan right
so anyway
i knew what roger kelly looked like so
i'm like you know i'm looking at each
person in there now that's nothing
that's not him that's not him
um he wasn't there so but i figured okay
well you know we drove all the way up
here to thurmont
i don't want to leave empty-handed you
know i want to talk to some klansmen and
maybe they can tell us
how to get a hold of roger i mean i had
roger's address and phone number
but um you know i wanted to meet him
that night so
uh i said to mary i said come on let's
go over here and sit one of these first
two booths
because if the clan is in here they'll
come to us to get us out of their booth
right
right so she's all right so we're going
to sit in the booth
nobody bothered us everything was cool
you know nobody said a word we stayed
there for a little while we migrated
over to the bar
sat there i chatted with the guy sitting
next to me like i was lost looking
through the highway
he gave me directions very polite and we
left so
i did not accomplish what i set out to
do that night mary was working out of my
house
so she came down the next morning monday
morning i said here here's roger kelly's
phone number
you give him a call and uh tell him that
you know that you're working
for a man who's writing a book on the
clan would he consent
to sitting down and giving your boss an
interview however
do not tell mr kelly that i'm black
if he asks go ahead and tell him don't
lie to him i said but don't allude to it
don't give him reason to
to ask the reason why uh i didn't want
him to know see i could have called him
myself i'm the one who had the phone
number
but i did not want him to pick up in my
voice that i'm black
so i'm not talking to you click and the
whole project would have ended before it
ever got started
but i knew that if she called he would
know by her voice
this is a white lady and i know the
mentality well enough to know
that he would not automatically think
this white woman is working for
a black man especially a black man who's
writing a book on the clan
because they did not exist my book would
become the first
all right so she called him and another
reason was this
even if he knew i was black and agreed
to do the interview
he might have different answers prepared
in the interim for a black interviewer
than he would have for a white
interviewer
asking the same question so i want to
make sure it was spontaneous very candid
so she got it she called him and she got
a hold of him
and he agreed to do the interview he
didn't ask what color i was or nothing
so we set it up in fact he invited us
over to his house and then something
came up that day we had to reschedule
so i said look let's just set it up for
the motel above the silver dollar lounge
you know that would be on neutral
territory she said all right
so we rescheduled and um
mary and i got to the hotel several
hours early
because oftentimes they will send out
scouts
to check out the place and check out who
they're meeting with
and then word gets back to the grand
dragon or the imperial wizard or whoever
you know i don't want anybody to know
that i was black and was he
he was at that point a grand dragon a
grand dragon okay
so i got this super early
i had mary go in and get the room i
stayed out of the lobby
and then um i would just call the hotel
from across the parking lot
from the pay phone over there find out
what room i'm in
from her and then um i just go through
the outside
up the stairs to the room so we did that
and um
i gave her some money and i sent her
down the hall to get soda pop out of the
machine
and put it in the ice bucket fill it
with ice get it cold
i wanted to be hospitable when mr kelly
arrived offer him an ice cold beverage
i had no idea what this man was gonna do
would he come in the room
would he look at me and say no i'm not
talking to you and walk away or would he
attack me or whatever
in any event i was going to be
hospitable and say you know what you
care for a cold beverage
foreign